when you get these readings or even
let's say Reiki like reiki's something
that can be done at a distance I
remember that I remember a long time ago
getting a reading and I was like oh we
should do this on FaceTime so that we
can see each other and the moment that
she needed to tap in she did what I did
10 minutes ago I closed my eyes and I
tapped in I watched you do it yeah I'm
pers I'm I'm receiving I'm becoming I'm
actually becoming aware of the
information in the field as opposed to
learning it so do you know what you were
doing when you close your eyes the
amplitude and location of alpha brain
waves in the brain changes dramatically
so if you want to have people talk about
Alpha Waves Alpha brain waves are very
common and very powerful and they're
nothing special unless they're organized
in a certain way but when you close your
eyes your alpha waves go up a lot and
you looked upwards so if you look up
with your eyes closed especially
focusing on your third eye if I had to
look the electrodes on your head we
would detect you going into a very
powerful Alpha state which is why when
I'm teaching people these neurofeedback
things what I'm doing is I'm putting in
dark Chambers because Darkness helps and
I'm teaching them some things you do to
make it even more powerful but what you
did to tap in was you just basically
probably tripled the power of your Alpha
brain waves and if I looked at your
brain waves I would predict we would see
unusually strong amplitude of waves I
don't know how organized they'd be and
probably more than a little bit of a
lower level brain wave that would
probably be more organized than normal
and because of what you do for a living
because you're highly intuitive and I
mean I picked that up the first time we
talked like you're you're paying
attention to stuff so but that's
happening in order to tune in I do the
same thing I'm like you close your eyes
I don't know sometimes I do this once I
do this and you you kind of look up and
then there's something you connect to
and that's why I said look at you
download yeah because so here's a
question
have you just done that since you were a
kid did you just know how to do that did
someone teach that to you because how
did you get that skill that's a great
question I mean I can remember being in
go-karting at probably I started when I
was 10 but I probably was you know 12
when I remember maybe doing it because I
just don't remember doing it right away
but I would sit there and just visualize
perfect laps and no one ever told me to
do that no one ever said hey sit down
and do some visualization techniques and
skills and I just decided I would
visualize the perfect lapse and I
imagined the car like it the go-kart
feeling exactly like I wanted hitting my
marks exactly correctly and so that's
kind of the first memory I have of that
but I I honestly I can't no no no I
don't really feel like I've been taught
even my
sort of spiritual awarenesses to my own
patterns of my being and why I am like I
am I mean I have therapists trust me but
it's never the breakthroughs don't
happen with them they happen on my own
they're a little spontaneous and they're
sort of like a there's a trigger
um but yeah things kind of yes things
come to me
so do you see like past lives and stuff
like that or do you have readings of
those sure I actually was in Sedona this
weekend and oh my God I'm going there
next week oh really okay very
interesting I want to know what you're
doing because I want to know if I can
come
um and I I was with this girl that I was
mentioning is very very very tapped in
and I did a past life regression but I
done I did it in a different way I've
had a couple past life I've had one
other past life regression
um and it was basically information
coming at me and she tapped into the
field and told me things and I'd ask
questions and oh that's cool I like like
akashic records reading kind of thing
pretty much that's what it felt like
more like as opposed to what I had this
weekend which was more of a past life
regression than I did so were you
experience the life yeah where I
experienced the life I saw the life I
told the story of the life as opposed to
someone telling me a story and I was put
into like a really this is an
interesting thing I want to know it what
the science of this is because you're so
well balanced between the two so they
took me into like a deep meditation
slowing my slowing everything down and I
I left you know I I was I I was gone but
as soon as he asked the first question
I answered
and I don't remember what was being said
before that point in time it was just
sort of like a meditation to get me my
me slowed down and tapped in and
um and so I asked him when it was over
with I said did I miss a question that
you asked he's like no he said you as
soon as I asked that you answered and I
was like whoa because I was gone but I
heard the question and answered and
that's when I came to was like at the
end of his sentence and I answered the
question but I was gone before that so
where was what was happening with my
brain waves at that point in time that I
could hear him but I wasn't coherent
like I wasn't with it I wasn't present
but I was still hearing him
when you say you weren't present were
you unaware of your body
yeah I was like it was as if I felt like
I was asleep okay you were asleep but
but you you still felt like you were in
your body you didn't like dissolve into
the universe kind of thing
no I wasn't I wasn't having sort of an
out-of-body experience that I was like
oh hang on a second let me come back
into my body to you know room you know
answer this question I just was it's
just blank there was like it was like a
blankness and then all of a sudden the
question was asked and I was like
answered the question
um okay so you were you had dropped into
um really the the subconscious state the
dreaming State and the in neuroscience
and people I'm not a neuroscientist I
just helped to develop like a
neuroscience company but my training is
not a neuroscience I'm just very
interested because I've been doing
neurofeedback on myself for 25 years
which is why I can do a lot of what I
can do so there's a state that you're in
when you're you're daydreaming and when
you're having a real dream it's even
deeper and these are different levels
and locations in the brain of what
neuroscientists will symbolize the Theta
state which is a range of things but
that's like saying oh you're listening
to music that is in the C chord like
well was it polka or it was it Metallica
because those are kind of different but
they're both can be in the C chord right
so what we don't really have good
language because it's all complex math
so what you did is you dropped into
a portion of the world of theta which is
a very big world and that's the world of
the subconscious that's where you
connect to the collective Consciousness
that's where you go to see the akashic
records and when I say to go there you
have to know how to play the right music
for lack of a better word the right
patterns within that
um so you'll see people saying well I
did some alpha or I did some Theta and
like well okay like what song did you
play I don't know well that's because
that's the hard part so you ended up
installing that app let's say or using
that app that allowed you to be at the
very upper level of theta where you're
dipping into Dreamland dissociative but
you had enough Alpha presence that you
were still able to hear and reply
um
so where are we going as humans and are
we returning or are we going somewhere
new
oh man that's a tough one
um
the most
well some of this is just opinion but
it's opinion based on you know math and
science and and also a lot of spiritual
stuff and experiential
information field Theory seems to
explain the world the most where
everything is actually a field of
information so all the stuff that we see
and sense including time including our
bodies and all that stuff is
representations of information and
there's some math that proves this and
it's the one explanation that explains a
lot of even those yogic cities we talked
about before that explains some of the
quantum effects that we know are real
and this isn't like Quantum like hey
let's do a Quantum like Quantum is
misused all over the place in marketing
do you have if you had any Quantum prune
juice lately because I'm sure there is
some right like but in Quantum biology
you get a PhD in this it's a hard
science trying to figure out how
electrons behave in biology differently
than they do in semiconductors like it's
super technical stuff above my pay grade
um but information field Theory explains
a lot of that stuff and it says that
Consciousness itself is a field and ours
just evolved so that when our field is
in these meat suits
then
um we use the user interface that's in
these meat suits and there are some
people who are atheists who are
listening I'm gonna say well you know
that that's not true there's no such
thing as reincarnation and I only get
one one time through okay cool
um I would argue that there's emerging
evidence that that probably isn't true
but there's a very rational reason that
you should believe in past lives
why here's what it is okay and this is
why I chose as a computer science guy
who was raised as an atheist okay so I
didn't have a particular particular
spiritual bent to what I did in fact I
thought anyone who believed in anything
spiritual was an idiot until I was about
30 and just had a few wake-up calls like
oh maybe there's something to learn here
here's to being open-minded there you go
right
so
if reincarnation is real
then I don't need to be afraid of dying
because it's just starting the video
game over again it's inconvenient
okay now I can live my life without as
much fear so I can make better decisions
from a state of consciousness and
thought
now
if I'm wrong I won't know it
okay so I win either way right so it is
probably stupid to not believe in
reincarnation just because reincarnation
as a concept creates more freedom in
your life now and if it's the only life
you have great welcome to more freedom
and if it's real then great you win you
cannot lose by choosing to believe in it
even with no evidence
so religion's a trap
I think organized religion has some
serious
um some serious limitations because what
it's doing is is installing a lens on
reality that you didn't choose and this
is why most religions are like can we
have them for the first seven years of
life because after that conscious
subconscious programming yep and then
you can undo that and that's a lot of
what I've done I've spent six months
plus of my life with electrodes on my
head going in and turning off alerts
that come from organized religion that
come from society that come from pop
culture that come from bullies that come
from the best intentioned parents on the
planet still screw up all the time
because they're human right so you go
through and you turn off all that so the
goal is to be as little emotionally
reactive to negative things as possible
what I believe is that when we're in
these bodies
in fact I don't just believe this I can
prove it
um you're not the Observer of reality
right you've heard this thing the
observer effect Schrodinger's cats okay
so for for people listening
uh if you have something that might
happen when someone pays attention to it
it happens and if they don't pay
attention to it there's no Observer then
it just continues being a possibility
forever and this is provable with like
hard scientific uh radiographic paper it
it's incredibly mind-boggling so I mean
if no one if no one you know hears the
tree fall in the forest did it make a
sound kind of thing it's like Zen Cohen
land but it's real
so
if that's going on and that's a part of
our reality
remember earlier I mentioned that your
brain doesn't get a signal of reality
until at least 240 milliseconds
after something happens
um
so who's observing it
who's observing it it turns out the
front line Observer with its own
Consciousness is a subcellular component
of your cells called the mitochondria
they're not power plants in your cells
they're environmental sensors in your
cells that sense the environment then
decide whether they're going to make
electricity or neurotransmitters or sex
hormones or inflammatory signaling
molecules
oh
you mean there's
billions and billions of these things
there's between 500 and 15
000 mitochondria and every one of your
cells that's not a red blood cell so
your body has way more of those than
there are cells in your body and those
things were ancient bacteria that well I
would say they moved into the cells that
are us and took over two billion years
ago and they're still driving the show
because they sense reality they decide
what to do and then we take credit for
it a quarter second later that's the
seat of intuition it's also the seed of
manifestation because they're the
environmental sensors they're the first
line observers of reality and when you
see the guys from the secret many of
whom I've gotten to know over the course
of years and you look at Napoleon Hill's
work you look at the way you visualize
when you were 10 years old you were
manifesting the [ __ ] out of things
Danica and you were using your
mitochondria to do it you were teaching
them to program their interface to
reality to look for Success instead of
to look for failure or lack of Love or
what whatever the hell bad programming
you got somewhere so what I've had to do
probably because I had really bad
programming was go through and reprogram
all that stuff so that my mind
automatically and my body and my tissues
and my cells and my mitochondria
automatically look for the things I want
in my life I'm still working on that by
the way
yeah high five to the humility of it
[Music]